the vast Evergreen arocaria and
gustifolia trees also known as the
Brazilian Pine have long been revered in
Brazil's Southern Highlands standing up
to 40 meters they can live for 400 years
they're deeply intertwined with the
local ecosystem and with the culture of
the indigenous shockling people but now
the trees are close to disappearing this
family are doing what they can to save
them
in order to be able to take the tree out
of the extreme risk of Extinction we
need millions of trees so far we've
succeeded in planting thousands but we
need to reach Millions
the loss of trees is threatening the
community's way of life
I usually say that the chocolate do not
exist without autocardia just as there
is no orukaria without the shockling
therefore both our people and our
culture also at risk of extinction
because we no longer have our
traditional food
they eat the seeds similar to large pine
nuts and rely on the trees for medicine
and spiritual practice before planting
the shockling began a ritual with dance
and prayer
calling for the seedlings protection
take a treat 12 to 15 years to produce
seeds of its own around 97 of the Pine
Forest has been lost to deforestation
through logging and urbanization the
shockling people say former president
gyro bolsonaro's hostile attitude toward
them has made their lives worse after
Decades of persecution
we indigenous people are not taking care
of this only for ourselves we are taking
care of it for the whole planet so the
challenge is to keep this Force intact
because there are many people who invade
our indigenous land to hunt to extract
the wood that we have which is our
wealth there are also miners gold miners
they see planting the trees as a form of
resistance trying to save their culture
and environment for generations to come
rahila Muhammad Al Jazeera